es una de las mayores filtraciones de
documentos financieros e implica al
menos 35 líderes mundiales los pandora
papers han puesto también en evidencia a
políticos latinoamericanos desde
estrategias para no pagar impuestos
ocultar y blanquear dinero a paraísos
fiscales en países como panamá en el
caso del presidente ecuatoriano la sola
investigación indica que operó con 14
sociedades inscritas en paraísos
fiscales algo que niega cumplo con lo
expuesto en la ley todos mis ingresos
han sido declarados y he pagado los
impuestos correspondientes en ecuador'
siempre con transparencia y frontalidad
ante el pueblo ecuatoriano
para sebastián piñera dirigente de chile
el panorama es parecido los papeles lo
acusan de participar en la compraventa
de la minera dominga en las islas
vírgenes británicas
el presidente nunca ha participado ni ha
tenido información alguna respecto del
proceso de venta de minera dominga
operación que se produjo en 2010 cuando
el mandatario ya no tenía ninguna
participación en la administración de
esas empresas junto a las dos líderes el
escándalo también salpicó a luís
abinader el mandatario dominicano fue
acusado de tener dos sociedades
off-shore en panamá junto a familiares
elpresidente abinader presentó toda la
arquitectura legal con la que maneja los
activos del patrimonio acumulado por el
esfuerzo empresarial propio de toda su
familia como parte de estos activos
fueron declaradas diversas compañías
extranjeras como pocos presidentes en el
mundo otros como el rey de jordania
también aparecen en los documentos el
palacio real justificó el secretismo con
respecto a sus propiedades en eeuu y
reino unido- por cuestiones de seguridad
y en rusia desde el kremlin no ven
evidencia de dinero escondido en el
entorno cercano de vladimir putin